114 cars auctioned off for a total of
129 million dollars yep that happen
every year in August car lovers flock on
maps to California's Monterey Peninsula
for the country's fanciest Auto Show but
if you're trying to wrap your head
around what kind of car can fetch over a
million dollars let's start with the
1959 Ferrari 250gt okay if it sounds
nuts to spend more than eighteen million
dollars on a car then you don't know
much about this Ferrari like the fact
that it's a successful racing car you're
allowed to drive on the street or that
it has a lightweight aluminum body in
its original feet 12 inches or that
Ferrari only made nine cars of its kind
so yeah 18 million is a lot but now you
get it don't you in the early 1980s
od started winning rally races with the
four-wheel drive Quattro Italian
automaker Lancia fought back with the
Delta s for the lightweight car packed a
supercharger and a turbocharger to make
more than 500 horsepower from a small
four-cylinder engine that's enough boom
to hit 60 miles per hour in under two
seconds this is the street-legal version
of the car which Lancia had to make so
it could get the race dedicated version
into competition you know Paul Newman is
an actor but he thought of himself as a
racecar driver and a good one at that he
and dick barber drove this Porsche 935
to a second-place finish in the 1979 24
hours of limo with Newman and others at
the wheel this 750 horsepower car
competed in more than 70 races over the
next decade winning plenty of them
thanks to its six cylinder engine and
two turbochargers if you ever need an
argument for spending too much money on
an Italian suit here it is you're
looking at a 1954 Aston Martin db4 but
one that's wearing a lusciously curvy
body designed by famed coach builder
Nucci / Tony the sharp crease in the
hood makes room for a sense
cylinder engine everything else is there
to look fantastic a Bart made this car
if you can call it that to do one thing
set speed records with help from
coachbuilder Pininfarina it fitted a
wind tunnel tested body over a 7.5 liter
engine with half a steering wheel and a
four gear transmission a Bart's test
drivers logged eight records in three
days in 1960 including an average speed
of 119 miles per hour over more than
6,000 miles sadly no one put down enough
money to take this one home but that
means it could still be yours